why do you think we we love fighting so
much
i think it's because we're good at it
we want something from it yeah yeah
it gives us something we want something
from a gift of status
it's the beginning of this time the
strongest man in the world achilles
since
the since achilles everybody wanted to
be the toughest man in the world
king of the hill yeah
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of hot boxing
i am evan britton and i'm mike tyson
mike we got a great guest a legend yes
the champion
from the beginning one of the og's ken
shamrock well thank you very much man
hey listen i'm honored to be sitting at
the table here did you start the lions
then
i did or wow take us to that
yeah it's uh i remember when i was going
over to japan
uh they hadn't started it here um the
bare knuckle no rules
it hadn't started so when i went over
and actually saw this
this um videotape of what these guys
were doing because one of my students
had actually showed it to me and said
hey look what these guys are doing over
there
and i was looking at i was going wow i
mean they're literally punching like
open hand strikes
and then they're kicking and ning and
then when they went to the ground they
were like
doing all these like leg locks and arm
bars and i was like what is that i mean
i never saw anything like that before
you either were a striker or you were
a wrestler and at that time i was more
of a wrestler and so i saw that i said i
don't want to do that
so i got with a friend of mine who was
doing pro wrestling his name was dean
malenko
great shooter great wrestler so he
introduced me to his dad
which had sammy saranaca who was the
promoter for japan
uh in florida and so i flew out there to
do a tryout
and my tryout consisted of fighting four
different guys in the gym they weren't
from japan they were american guys that
were already going over there
and where i came from i came from group
home in the streets and kind of grew up
rough
and so for me fighting was a natural
thing for me so when i went into the gym
i basically did
dirty boxing and and wrestled him the
ground and just beat the snot out of
these guys who were supposedly these
trained guys from japan
i was like i felt i felt pretty good
like wow okay
well then sammy calls me i'm saying hey
how'd you like to come to japan and and
um
and uh you know visit our facilities
like i said yeah sounds good
so i go down there and i remember when i
walked into the dojo right after i got
off the plane they picked me up it's a
12-hour flight they picked me up they
drive me to the dojo and they said okay
gear up and i was like huh i was like
oh now he's like yeah i gear up so i
said all right so i put my gear on and
i'm standing there warming up and these
two young boys come in
and he says okay uh go with the you know
this young boy and so i go with him and
i pretty much dominated him just beat
him up
i was about 20 minutes or so so he puts
in the other young boy and he's like
okay go with him
so cool so i go with him and i'm i'm
feeling pretty cocky right now
so i get in i start thumping him i'm
gonna throw him around boom boom boom
and he says okay good well as i'm
sitting there these other two guys walk
in
and these two guys that i see now are
masa katsu funaki and menorah suzuki the
two guys that i saw on the tape fighting
and i was like that's those dudes there
and i was like
what are they doing here
well come to find out they were going to
be there for me
sammy goes hey you still got more in you
of course me
i never turned down a fight i was like
yeah i'm good
so he throws 12 hours on a plane two
sparring matches
already but i mean i literally did
handle these guys and i think those guys
weren't there to really shoot on me
even though i probably could have beat
them because they were young boys but i
think they were there just just to kind
of warm me up
those two guys walked in to see whether
or not i would go ahead and go with them
after i was tired a little bit
because this was all a test so i was
like yeah let's go
well the first guy comes in it's menorah
suzuki he's probably 180 pounds maybe
five nine so he's a smaller guy i'm
going about 220
right and i'm benching 605 i'm a strong
guy i'm
you know i got wrestling background i
got boxing a little bit dirty boxing i
was like yeah i'll squash this guy
so we get going and i take him down i
slam him on top of him and next thing i
know i wake up
whoa i'm like uh
did i win he's standing above me going
hey he's handing his hand out to me and
he's saying something japanese i'm like
what happened so he goes you say he goes
you want to go some more and i was go
yeah of course i'm thinking what just
happened to me so i get down and i start
wrestling again next thing i know i'm
he's got me in his leg luck and it hurts
but yet i'm fighting like a dog just
trying to get out and sammy's going tap
you know how to tap and i'm looking at
what what what are you saying
like remember nobody knows what tapping
is nobody understands what that is
no one said hey we're playing uncle they
said fight
so i was like i don't know what that is
i don't know what that means and he says
mary if it
hurts especially in training just tap
the mat
and he'll he'll let go so he tells me
after about five minutes this guy
torquing on my leg and i'm like trying
to fight to get out and i'm not showing
any pain it's hurting right he's going
if it hurts tap
i was like what so i tap the guy beats
me up
literally just thrashes me 180 pound guy
for 20 25 minutes
so i after he gets done he's okay good
and he says uh you ready to go a little
bit more and of course
me and i says absolutely i'm not going
to quit i'm not giving up man
so here comes fennake now finaki's about
six foot six
one about 205 pounds so he's much bigger
and i'm thinking oh my goodness this
little guy just killed me and i saw
those two guys fighting and he won
so i said bring it so i went after him
too the same thing
i just got beat up just tortured and so
after it was over
sammy goes okay you good and i said no
we go some more got somebody else and i
was beat up but i just i felt like man i
i wanted to do more because i felt like
i let myself down i let everybody else
down and i just wanted to try to
try to prove myself even more but he
said no no it's good and i said are you
sure man i could do more because i
thought like i blew it
and he's no no it's good good good well
they send me home
and i get a call like a month later and
the whole time i'm thinking i blew it
man these guys don't like me well he
calls me back and said how would you
like to fight
and i was like yes absolutely
he says why don't you come up to japan
for a little while and we'll train you
and get you prepared for the fight
and so i flew up six weeks before the
fight that we were supposed to have and
i remember training every
single day i spent my whole day in there
it was like a dojo they fed me
those guys slept there but i slept
somewhere else but i end up staying
there from six in the morning till six
at night
and i constantly trained every day with
the young boys when i had my fight i won
my first
fight now the whole thing on that was
what sammy was trying to find out was
which is do you have the heart of a
warrior
do you have the ability to never give up
and not
quit that's what they were looking for
and that's how
i actually structured my dojo because it
didn't matter how much skill you had it
didn't matter how good you were how
athletic you were what it mattered to
them and to me
was whether or not you had the mentality
of never giving up and always fighting
to be better and that's literally where
i got it from
it's the fighter spirit the warrior
spirit yeah that's what it's all about
you've talked about that much what it's
all about you know some of these guys
don't even look like much you know they
look really skinny guys look they wear
glasses
you know they never curse then they get
in the ring they beat the [ __ ] out of
you
yeah it's just it doesn't have to do
with the something with the mind it's
something with the brain because some
people are almost like
they never talk they're introverts and
they're great fighters
you know i was just like i mean you look
at suzuki when he came in i mean he was
i mean he was a small guy he was five
nine 180 pounds he did not look like
much but boy did i find out different
because listen when you were in the ufc
there was no weight limit
no man oh i can remember though
your fee might have been fighting a guy
80 pounds heavier
right yeah 100 pounds yeah i mean over
300 pound dudes in there
it was awesome too because you think
about it man it was literally style
against style yeah
did you ever fight dan severant i did i
fought him twice
yeah i beat him the first time and then
the second time we
went to a distance that's when he was
running right he was running around
yeah that was the 907 his but that was
the worst
fight in ufc history and i was a part of
that fight
partially blamed for that fight it was
bad
it was bad did he just not want to fight
no it wasn't him i think it was a little
both of us
severing him came in because the first
time i fought him i choked him out
quickly
so the second time he came in he had the
strategy of like okay i'm not gonna
shoot on him
he's gonna stay around the outside and
make me attack him
the only problem with that was that
before that i had broken my nose in
training and i fractured a little rib
and i also had a meniscus tear on my
knee so going into that fight obviously
i couldn't back out of the fight
and they took away that was the time
where they actually came in and said if
you punch
we're gonna arrest you like it's illegal
you can't do that
and uh just two weeks prior to that over
the border there in canada they
literally arrested the main event
because they told them the same thing
and they went ahead and punched
well the ufc came in and said oh yeah
we'll we'll
we're gonna find you guys at our leisure
so in other words they were basically
saying
we'll warn you a couple times 10 times
and then we'll find you after that so
really what they were doing was saying
go ahead and do it
we'll abide by the rules but we'll do it
through warnings and things of that
nature well i chose not to do that
i chose not to punch because i had a
group home for kids i was teaching kids
you can accomplish anything you want in
life
as long as you stay within the rules you
can push the boundaries a little bit
but stay with the rules you will be able
to accomplish whatever you want in life
go get it and then i was asked and put
in that situation
to where i was told that it was okay to
break the rules because even though they
were laid down
it was okay to do that because we
weren't going to do anything other than
find you or not find you but warn you
several times
even though there will be no fine on the
end of it and i just felt like that in
my position and what i was representing
at the time with those kids
that i was sending the wrong message to
those kids that were young
and that they were up and coming and
trying to find where they belonged in
life and how they were going to live
life
that i just didn't want to represent
that so i chose not to strike
and unfortunately because i chose that
and because of the way the fight was
not that it was dan's fault either
because he had a strategy of not losing
because if i got him on the ground i'd
beat him
so he was hoping that i would come in on
him and he would get top position
and uh because of the the different
natures of where he was at and where i
was at
that's the kind of fight we had it was
oh interesting yes
very interesting now you guys have met
before you guys are old friends yes
absolutely i thought
that wasn't your last fight with gracie
was that your last fight song was in
norfolk virginia somewhere
no you mean the one where he lifted my
nuts into my throat
oh no kicked them in the ball
yeah and the ref didn't see it oh wasn't
that
what was that in virginia right oh man
where was that one at uh
norfolk no i don't even remember that
was that
um was that norfolk i thought it was
yeah i don't remember was that because
i'm still trying to find my nuts
[Laughter]
that was a tricky one yeah he had him
here too hoist was here right yeah
yeah yeah here's the thing with hoist
man what uh what's your beef with him
there's really no beef there you know i
mean i'm the kind of guy that just
you know i i get into a fight i get in
people's houses i'm talking about
personalities
you know i i have character
i have a certain thing that i follow
when a guy at least i would and i think
most fighters would when you hit
somebody in the nuts and you know you
did
you don't go well that's the way we used
to fight i was like
what it's like now you're saying you did
it on purpose
and then not have any remorse about it
right literally just go
like oh well that's you know oh well it
happened uh that's the way we used to
fight he should have been ready for and
i was like
dude you have so much uh
credibility in this sport so much people
want to honor you for because of what
he's done in the sport
and then you have that kind of character
where you're like
oh yeah um that's just the way it is i i
and then not wanna like literally fight
me again like i said dude
that was a low blow let's do a rematch
and literally
he doesn't want the rematch because in
my opinion the only reason why he hit me
low was because he knew he didn't want
to be in the ring with
me and that's the rivalry i think that
union had a rivalry
yes it was a rivalry yeah no question
and this you can't take anyway
anything that guy's done was tremendous
but man just
uh for for that's interesting yeah to
have that kind of
manual brass to be able to sit there and
and accept the fact you need some of the
nuts and that's okay with you
that that that bothers me yeah that
bothers me
yeah that makes sense it makes sense
who's the greatest fighter you ever
fought
i would probably have to say uh
masakatsu fanaki uh he helped train me
and so for me to fight him and be my
trainer and be able to
beat him that right there was really
when it told me that you know okay
i'm getting where i need to be to be a
professional fighter uh his
his uh his ceiling was my floor and um
that's a sign of a true
teacher somebody that really wants you
to succeed and so i was able to do that
and so
when i fought in the first time man it
was it was tough because almost like he
knew he was already in my head like he
knew where i was going all the time
that's awesome awesome talk a little bit
about
where you grew up and where you come
from because i know that's
that's really so much of the dna of your
fighting spirit
yeah i was uh i was born in georgia um
in macon
uh and i was at warner robins hospital
and
my biological mother uh was a go-go
dancer of course
you know in those days stripper dancer
and we were left home quite a bit i have
two older brothers one's doing life in
prison right now the other one's
you know surviving
they went in some bad directions just as
i did as a young kid and
fighting all the time you know 10 years
old i had strong arm robbery
um got stabbed behind a store in you
know in a fight
end up in a hospital with a knife in my
arm and
10 years old i was a ward of the court
uh became uh
my parents became the judge and the
probation officer
i went through several placements very
angry very frustrated hated the world
anybody that said anything to me i would
fight him at a drop of a hat no matter
how big
or small they were i just had no thought
of what i was doing i just wanted to
kill something i wanted to
fight somebody i just want to release
that anger and that frustration i had
inside of me
and so i went through several placements
and unconsciously i was searching for
something better because all these other
homes i went to it just felt like
i was a number i wasn't a person they
weren't like treating me as an
individual they didn't care what my
problems were they just said hey do your
time
we'll send you home but yet they weren't
trying to fix me like they weren't
trying like what's that going to do
that's not going to help me
but unconsciously i didn't know that i
just knew i wanted something better
i'd failed a bunch of them i ended up in
in juvenile hall i remember the
probation house came to me and said hey
this is your last chance
if you fail this placement you're going
to go to california youth authority
and i was like oh wow i mean i'm 10
years old right okay what
big deal right you're gonna give me
three squares and three squares a meal
and i'll hang out with my friends right
that wasn't even a threat didn't think
anything of it so i
ended up going to the shamrock boys home
after failing all those different
placements i was probably around 13
years old at the time
i entered the shamrock boys home my
original last name was kilpatrick
i ended up there and the first thing i
noticed
was that when bob shamrock took in i was
with two other boys that the
probationary officers
brought us up and he sat down and he
literally sent the probation officer
off with some coffee and some cookies
with our cook that was there
and he talked to us i mean like that
never had use they sent us off and they
talked to probation officer well he
sat us down into this bar and it had
like coke and cookie and ice creams all
this thing in this bar thing and it was
like
i mean we walked into this house it was
a mansion and i was like dude this is
the wrong house
and i literally thought to myself when i
walked into this place i was i don't
belong here like this
i can't live here i'm not wearing a tie
at dinner i'm not gonna you know
everything was weird to me it was like
there's what's the catch
and uh so when i got there i was really
defensive and in fact in my mind i felt
like i was gonna run away steal
everything as much as i could
and i would run away sell it and you
know how how
as young people think that we can make
the money last so i was thinking about
all these other things that i could
steal and run away but
something just kept me there and it was
just more i think it was more curiosity
what's the deal now remember as i stayed
there longer and longer
the things that were happening were i
remember there was this kid
who was a great artist he went to school
and he was more introvert like
i was outward i want to beat people up
everything you knew you could see
well some of them were like smoking weed
or they were into drugs or they were
into rapping or singing they were more
inward right and they would let it out
through
art or whatever else singing or whatever
else right well
me it was through violence and
uh so here's this kid
like he goes to school and he's going to
continuation school
and he draws this picture in school
where he was like killing all these
people he's standing on top of the
bodies
and literally with his blood everywhere
and it said kill them all and so the
teachers freaked out oh my goodness this
kid's sick and they sent him home
well when he gets home i remember my my
my mom
looked at the picture and she goes wow
that's good because it was really a good
pic drawing i mean it was really good
very talented
wow but what was on the picture was like
disturbing right
but she saw through that because he was
releasing something
but she saw the talent and so she said
after multiple discussions with them
said you know you can take an hour we
had a study hour an hour study hour you
could take that hour
and that you can literally draw whatever
you want to draw but part of that hour i
want you to draw an addition onto this
house
so take that time we want this this and
this
but the other time you can draw what you
want whatever you want
so he draws this edition and it comes
out like beautiful
she says well how are you going to build
it he's like what do you mean
he says well where are the specs i mean
how far is the measurements to where
when where and the kid goes uh
uh so she says well you know why don't
you go figure that out
so literally put somebody with him to
help him actually understand
the architect part of that of that
drawing that kid went on to college and
became an architect
right only because somebody saw the
talent in his
aggression and anger well same thing
happened to me
right i mean i was outward with it my
father her
adopted father bob shamrock put me in
sports he put me in football
yeah and i remember man the first time i
hit somebody in a in a practice
i hit him so hard he was blowing snot
bubbles i mean i am hard you're like
[ __ ] yeah i mean i
they gave me a plastic helmet plastic
shoulder pads and i just
i just like ah and i just hit people and
people thought i was on crack
drugs because i was so intense i became
relevant
because i was good at something before
that i was a punk kid that was going to
die before i was 18.
now all of a sudden i got coaches
helping me with my homework
making sure i get good grades i got
teachers that are helping me
i'm i'm i'm dating the head cheerleader
yeah girls think about that like here i
was everybody would look at me like i
was weird and i had to play
to where now all of a sudden i was
important oh because i was good at a
sport
and i i literally latched onto that i
said okay
this is my way out and i latched on to
that and i became a football player and
a wrestler
i got scholarships and here's the thing
right i mean everybody goes through some
sort of sort of adversity
i remembered after i was there four
years i was a senior
i had the world by the balls i mean
literally i was it
one instant it was taken away
i walked into the wrestling room i
already played football i had a great
season
i walk into wrestling i was undefeated
that season
had not been beaten i walked in there
for the
after the season qualifying for state
i walk in that mats are not taped
together nobody's there i got people to
come in and help me
we start practicing and rolling around
nothing's put together right we just
rolled the mats out so we start
wrestling and coach says you better take
him down i want to do walls which is
conditioning drill
because i was kind of goofing off and i
remember in one moment
i took a step went to take him down i
slipped kid fell on top of me
kid was probably about 200 205 pounds i
was probably 170 pounds
broke my neck whoa boom done
i'm laying there on the ground he's
saying get up get up and i'm getting up
but i ain't moving and then literally
about 30 seconds in
i'm like i can't move
30 minutes later i'm snapped together in
a star wars board put a clamp on me pick
me up put me in the ambulance they take
me to reading california
right then they told me i broke my neck
i was like okay
how long am i out for it's like
doctor's like um you broke your neck i
said oh
i heard that how long am i out now i'm
not moving they got me clamped down
he's like uh let me look at the x-rays
and i'll get back to you well he
pulls my dad aside wasn't my dad then
but he pulls him aside and he explains
to him what
the deal is and you never play contact
sports again you know he's gonna have to
think about some other things and
so he comes in he starts to explain it
to me and i remember thinking to myself
wait a minute i didn't do anything wrong
why wha why is this happening
wait what this this camp only reason why
i
am where i'm at right now is because i
was good at something and you're telling
me i can't do that
say no no no no no that's not possible
that can't happen
and he's literally my dad says
listen you can lay there and pout or you
can get up and do something about it
and i was like he's right now
i took it different than the way he
meant it but i was like
yeah he's right how's this doctor
telling me what i can't do
he doesn't know me he has no idea what
i'm willing to do to get to where i want
to go
he doesn't know me so he can't tell me i
can't do this
and i literally in my mind as soon as i
got out of the hospital i remember i had
this halo on
this metal brackets attached to my chest
went through my bone my hip in my bone
and infused it in my front of my neck
here and
i remember i tore the bolts out in my
head twice because
i was working out one time and i got in
a fight another time with a halo on i
tore the bolts out of my head
i mean i just it was i had this
mentality like
you can't tell me i can't do something
because if it's something i really want
i'm gonna do it all right who was it
that you saw you said that was a bad i
said yeah i'm gonna be something like
that
it has been somebody you saw that you
said he ain't taking [ __ ] from nobody
nobody talks to him any kind of way but
respects him
i want to be like that well i to be
honest with you um
it wasn't uh a role model it was more of
a concept
exactly i understand yeah it was a
concept because the way i grew up
was i watched how the gangs worked and i
watched how the
guys in power worked and i thought to
myself i ain't nobody's punk
and um i'm gonna i'm gonna get to the
top of the food chain
in that world because that's how it's
gonna be run the baddest guy the
toughest guy the smartest guy
that's what i wanted obviously as things
progressed and i started seeing how the
real world works that wasn't the case i
knew those guys were punks everybody's
going to bend over and get their ass
checked when they went into prison
so nobody was nobody was that tough
nobody was that bad nobody was that much
power
so i really realized that early on and
then i thought more like
the sports industry was like okay now i
see where the power is at
you be good at something really good at
it and now you have the power
i literally watched you fight and i
remembered
the eye contact i remembered the
confidence i remember
beating fighters before you ever walked
into the ring if you watch
my fights over in japan and you watch
them really closely
that's how i entered my fights was that
i wanted to make sure that the guy that
i was fighting knew i was going to fight
him knew i was going to hurt him and
knew i was going to destroy him
and when i looked at him in the eyes
after all the other stuff i said and did
that he looked straight into my eyes
knew i was confident that i was going to
hurt him and a lot of that stuff i got
from you when you were fighting when you
walked into the ring a lot of that stuff
i picked up from you
so for me it was about winning the fight
before i ever walked into the ring that
was bruce lee winning the fight before
without fighting yeah you know i mean
that was his philosophy yeah
yeah art of war yeah and it's true
because you can destroy people's minds
before they ever get to the ring
fighting without fighting yeah you know
this episode of hot boxing is brought to
you by manscape
the best of men below the waist groom
and manscape
offers precision engineers tools for
your family jewels
they are obsessed with the giving you
the best trim for below your rim
get 20 off free trust me shipping with
code
tyson at manscape.com that's 20 off free
shipping
at manscape.com and use code tyson too
and your balls will thank you unless
you've been living under a rock
you've known that the nfl is back and
the nba players are in full swing
which can only mean one thing it's
winning season at my bookie
to start one and go to my book you just
use the promo code tyson
claim your 100 deposit match all the way
up to a thousand
bucks that means if you put 100 bucks in
you get another 100 bucks
it's easy easy way to jump start your
bankroll
nfl nba mlb they all got
all they're never too late to start your
own winning season
exclusively at my bookie
can jesus when did you uh when did
you start to gain feeling back in your
body
in the hospital well i i started to feel
sharp pains going down my arm and um
i remember when they showed the x-ray my
neck was like this i mean it was
literally hanging off
normally it's like that well i'd smash
the cartilage because what happened is i
pushed my chin down to my sternum
and then it came as it stretched it came
back down wham and it just
it stuck there and it literally was just
i mean you're talking i mean just inches
from me just being paralyzed or dead
right and i was very very fortunate very
blessed uh
that that i was able to recover from
that and not only recover from it but
you know become the athlete i am today
but it really was determination in my
mind
was that you know and it came from me
the streets that's that's where i got it
from was that
um i'm either going to lay down and die
or i'm going to stand up and fight
there's no other there's no there's no
in between you either do it or you don't
do it and that's really what what it was
about was really my
experience from the street was like i
have two
options you can't you there's no way
you're going to talk your way out of it
there's no way you're going to be a
a a what do you call that an ambassador
somebody that has good with words be
able to talk your way out of it because
you ain't getting that far
so either you're going to fight or
you're going to get beat up and and
that's just the way it was
wow [ __ ] man
can i ask you what is what is your
relationship
like with frank yeah
yeah wow that's uh you know i want to
love him
picture you guys together yeah i guess
yes
i i want to love the guy i want to help
i want to
embrace him he makes it so hard because
i know when my father passed away
he was passing away he was in the
hospital he was on response we brought
him home
he chose that he didn't want to be you
know doing
uh you know all the things he needed to
do to to live because he was pretty bad
off and
so i brought him home and and let him
pass away at home well and i remember
one of his his
requests were can you get frank i want
to talk to him i want to put aside our
our difference because they were
fighting at the time and so we called
and reached out to frank and frank said
he'd mourn at home he did not give my
father a chance
to ask for forgiveness he didn't give
him a chance to put that aside
and and i think today it haunts frank i
think that's why he's having issues and
the things that he's going through
is because of of that that he didn't
allow
for whatever reason he didn't allow that
to be put aside and
and to make things right this man
without this man i wouldn't be where i'm
at
and without this man he wouldn't be
where he's at and for him not to give
him that chance
it breaks my heart i don't hate him i
feel for him because i know the more
the longer he lives the more he has
family and different things that he
grows and understands how this works
the more it's going to eat at him that
he didn't honor the
the request that that his father wanted
wow um
how many kids did uh the shamrock family
bring
in well i know my dad had over 500 boys
wow within the time spirit the time
period that we were at the shamrock boys
home in
susanville i know he had it in anza
california for a short time i think
there was
i don't know maybe a 50 or 60 kids he
had there
but he and not only did he help the kids
in the home he always helping kids in
the community kids that were struggling
they weren't doing well at home he would
invite him out to the house he
gave him square meals he let him stay um
he was always
he was just one of those kind of guys
that was always reaching out and helping
kids
that was his thing he just he knew how
to i mean listen nobody knew how to deal
with me i mean i was i was a bad kid
yeah and he knew how to deal with me he
literally you know he
was the same way yeah he's telling a
story i was saying when it came to cuts
i saw this big you know i'm
from the gut i said 14 victoria master
wow
i'mma live here and i thought about the
same that's all about robbing them too
rob this year that's hard not to think
that you're a street person she's got
all this stuff
and he said no all this stuff is yours
you live here you're one of us
but i don't know i still wanted to rob
him and then he started talking to me
about
my character and this and that and he's
you know and i said who this guy i
thought it was some
gay guy or something so you look nice
you haven't what the [ __ ] is he talking
about
right what's the game what's he want
what the hell does he want
and i said what's this white guy go
teach me about fighting who what did i
[ __ ] find out you know me told me
about the character talking about the
spirit of fighting
you know that's bigger than fighting the
spirit of fighting
you know he just that one i became a
slave i said teach me more
well those two guys seem very
similar bob shamrock and customato
and what they who they were in the world
and i'm interested to hear from you guys
what do you think it is that
and i think i know but for our audience
what do you think
it was that he wanted oh there's no
question in my mind that
his true intentions were was to help a
troubled youth somebody that had the
ability
to be do better things in life i mean he
didn't reach out
to me because um he thought like well
i'm just gonna
you know help this kid he saw something
in me he literally saw something was
special
and he goes you know to be a shame that
somebody doesn't reach out and actually
help this kid reach his potential
because he can be great and i know
that's what he thought and so for him
to really the difference between
everyone else was that they weren't
talking a game they weren't
telling you something without producing
something
and he literally produced my anger and
my frustration and he showed me
how to take all that that that that
frustration and that ability to want to
kill and hurt people
and he literally said here go ahead take
it out on these guys here that are
playing football
take it out of these guys here that are
wrestling but here's the key
you got to stay within the rules yeah
you can go as hard as you want you'll be
as angry as you want you'll be as
frustrated as you want you can
you can explode hard as you want
but stay within that whistle stay within
that matted area
and you can go as hard as you want and
be whoever you want to be
within that rule and i it was hard for
me no question because i lost
control a lot of times but he'd always
bring me back and said hey
you know this is this is the rules right
here this is where you got to be
he said i'm not telling you you can't do
it i'm saying you got to do it within
this
and then once i started catching on to
that and all of a sudden
i became relevant and i was like whoa
i'm important like these guys like me
and
literally they didn't just like me as a
person but they liked what i could do
for them
that's fine because now i understood and
my father helped me understand that was
like they want something from you
you want something from them so you guys
work with each other and get what you
want
exactly if cousin was happy that made me
happy
if me knocking out people made him happy
[ __ ] i want to do it i want to knock out
of five people a day
really because that made them happy that
was my job i just wanted them to be
happy
and being happy made me happy the pride
on their face like
oh is that my dad yeah like whenever i
go in and pin a guy i
beat two state champions and i wasn't
even ranked i mean it was i was just got
there and he'd be on the phone talking
to his friends
the old friend oh he beat him and this
and that and he doesn't even have a lot
of fights he just started he beat the
champion of the neighborhood
he did this and that he feel proud oh
that major
made you like everything that you had
gone through and everything that you
were
all of a sudden you became loved and and
you were important to this human being
and
it it wasn't selfish it was they were
truly happy for you
big time and ken you've really
you've taken that and you've paid that
forward
right i mean you have your own group
homes
now for boys i did yeah you did i ran
those homes and
and uh we gave kids an outlet same thing
wanted to try to
do that nowadays with the way the laws
are on the way kids
lie and this and that and they and
you're a famous guy that polarized that
that's
crazy i could never my wife loves when
kids come to visit my kid over the house
i'm nervous
yeah when their friends come over the
house i don't know what these kids don't
know what they
did karen their parents planned them to
do i don't know they may think we
wealthy we live in this neighborhood in
this big [ __ ] house they may think we
have more money than we actually have
it's funny too because like i mean you
think about that man and
that's that's you people are so
out to be able to just i mean you look
at social media and everybody's out to
try to get a buck by suing her
or or posting something for himself yeah
and it's just
sick man and that's that's the truth man
you got to watch yourself
tell my wife don't leave me alone in
here with this [ __ ] name you're right
it's cleaner wait did she leave then you
can leave don't leave me alone with this
woman
this will ruin our life baby all this
are you gonna leave all this [ __ ] we
work [ __ ] go
one word can lose all this [ __ ] we as
hard we work we just came from nothing
baby
yeah let's imagine this this one was
gonna lose all this [ __ ] we got
uh all they got to say is one word man
they don't got to be true
you know all it has to do is say it and
the rumors go they don't even got to go
to court they don't have to do anything
but just say it and it's everywhere
it's all in social media whether it's
true or not true it was said and you're
dead no more
no more doing the um walton commercials
for you buddy
normal kentucky fried chicken commercial
yeah no more all-american guy hey well
hey i heard pornhub's hiring yeah
exactly
exactly that's about it oh
okay that's hysterical um
don't ask me how i know that yeah
um well what are you up to these days
man what do you spend your time on
well i tell you what man something that
um i think hopefully mike might be
interested in is i went up to
uh columbia and metidine and i did stem
cells
and oh man you know i'm one of those
kind of guys people say oh dude do this
man it was
game changing i was like yeah whatever i
heard that a million times
and i was like okay well then i actually
got footage from matt hughes
chuck liddell kevin i saw his story a
documentary
unbelievable and that's what sold me i
was like okay i'm gonna i'll give it a
try
so i go up there and i do this thing and
they put me under they give me all these
stem cells
i wake up one morning and they tell me
you're gonna be sore in these different
joint areas
and i was like okay so i wake up and i'm
gonna get up going to bathroom it's like
three four in the morning i get to go to
the bathroom and i go back down and lay
in bed and i was like
wait a minute it's like my shoulder's
swimming he's your shoulder everything
but
where i get really stiff is my lower
back of my neck because i broke my neck
twice in my lower back once
in the middle of my back's all jacked up
and i'm like there's no pain i got no
infl i got no information
i was like okay i'm gonna go to bed i'm
dreaming i wake up by nine o'clock next
morning i'm like i wake up again and i'm
like
i i don't have any inflammation i'm
still sewing shoulders and everything
but they warn that
and i was like wow this okay i'm gonna
slow down on this i'm not gonna jump out
of here and say everything's working
so i wait a week i couldn't raise my
arms above my head going to the airport
i'd go this high
because i've got a titanium ball in my
shoulder i mean completely reconstructed
so
i have a hard time with my arms within a
week to two weeks
bam i'm like wow this is a game changer
literally i went up to australia and i
did a 40 minute match with dan
severn i'd have never been able to do
that before these stem cell dreams
i've been out and now i'm in to do it
three weeks now i'm supposed to see more
results
david truett said hey this is just the
beginning man you're gonna see so many
results within six months
that it's going to be a game changer it
already is for me
so i'm like man if i can share this with
people and let them know how it's done
to me and they can help them man
i'm all about that so i hope that maybe
you'll
get a chance to at least see what that
is because i i really truly and i'm not
saying this just to say it i'm telling
you it is a game
changer down there listen
for sure but one thing too i want to
talk about is i want to talk about my
love
right please i fought in the very first
ufc
yeah yeah i fought over in japan with
open hand strikes
i fought with four ounce gloves on i
fought muay thai i've done it all i
fought everything i fought boxing i
sparred with guys to help them get ready
for their fights
i've done it all and the one thing that
i fell in love with was bare knuckle
and the reason why i fell in love with
it was because i felt like
like this is just pure i mean it's man
against man god given talent
and that there's nothing there that's
going to get in the way i mean you hit
with a jab it counts
right any time you hit somebody it
counts but if you miss it it also counts
because it works against you your hand
so i fell in love with that man and i
said you know if i ever get a chance
to bring back bare knuckle because they
started putting four ounces on glove
four ounce gloves on guys and started
saying
we're gonna make it safer well the
reality of that's not true
they wanted to protect the guys that
were winning the guys that were knocking
people out
because they knew they could him in the
back of the head the side of the head
and they wouldn't damage their hand
and and so they made it into a four
billion dollar business
kudos good job but that's not what i
fell in love with i fell in love with
the bare knuckle part because it was so
pure and i said you know i get a chance
to do that i'm going to bring it back
bare knuckle fighting valor bare knuckle
fighting
i'm bringing it back people kept
screaming stand them up stand them up
well we're standing them up nice man
why do you think we we love fighting so
much
[Laughter]
i think it's because we're good at it
[Laughter]
we want something from it yeah yeah yeah
it gives us something we want something
from it gives us status
since the beginning of time the
strongest man in the world achilles
since
the since achilles everybody wanted to
be the toughest man in the world
king of the hill yeah respect
respect then it works against you after
you get old
they start looking at you like what
happened to my respect
no even that becomes the form of respect
right well
yes yes depending on that even that
becomes a form
of respect yeah well i've seen this
emergence of bare knuckle
and i think it's really interesting and
so you you believe that or maybe the
science says
because it would make sense i mean you
put four ounces you put weighted
you know accessories on your on your
weapons
and that's gonna add damage you know
it's like a football helmet in football
you know really you're just putting a t
a
a spear on that thing you know giving a
guy a chance to do more damage without
hurting their hand
but you know and and and england bare
knuckle fighting is just brilliant
is it quicker it's quicker it is so fast
malinagi went in and fought uh lobov
um i think it was one of conor
mcgregor's guys
and it was really boxing against mma and
when a boxer goes into a bare knuckle
fight malonagi i think made a mistake
because he thought bare knuckle would be
like boxing well
that's crazy because you got to think
about in boxing you got eight ounce
gloves
well those eight ounces gloves are a lot
bigger so you could pick a boom you can
block
bare knuckle you can't block you know so
yeah use your footwork you got to be
moved more
and malaji came in there with the wrong
idea
he thought he could block yep and he got
he got lit up
and um so i think that's i really think
that's the exciting part of it because
it's almost like in the very beginning
days with ufc when they first started
out
it's like now we have that same concept
where you're trying to figure out
everybody says boxing's going to adapt
better or mma might adapt better and i'm
thinking to myself
i think it's the individual i think it's
the character of an individual
that says hey i'm going to come in i'm
going to learn because it's different
and a lot of these guys want to try to
think it's similar or the same it's not
bare knuckle is his own beast it's
different it's faster from the time the
bell rings
to the end of the bell in the third
round it's on there's no feeling out
process there's not a trend it's like
when he fought
it was like well on goal right i mean
you did
great yeah but now a lot of guys they
always want to kind of get that one or
two rounds and feel it out well in bare
knuckle you take one or two rounds and
feel it out and you're done
game over yeah what's your feeling on it
mike
it's interesting really um yeah um
with the rules that they have it's not
really like bare knuckle fighting boxing
they had different rules you know they
didn't have the um
marcus of queensberry three minutes and
one minute rest if you knocked the guy
down in 1880
if you knocked him down at the end of
the round so you knocked the guy down
ten times you're not that's ten rounds
you know so they had to change the rules
but um
i think it's pretty awesome it has a it
has um it has a base
yeah it wants to see it yeah i've seen
yeah so i think it's necessary well it
seems very
exciting i don't go like well one one
fighting sport
is worse than another spike but we're
fighting you can die
fighting that's an unwritten law when we
sign the contract that's the law that we
know because we've seen it over and over
again that's growing up being fighters
that's the unwritten law you can die
training uh in the fight
and it's i'm glad he said that because i
hear a lot of people trying to say bare
knuckles more dangerous or
boxing's more dangerous because more
people have died while baron hasn't been
it's been here forever but it's just
starting back again or mma is
to me it's this man every single combat
sport whether it's football
i mean even in soccer i mean there's
danger in any athletic sport so when
people talk about
this yeah people can get hurt yeah
somebody may die
but look at it like this anybody that
steps in the ring signs a contract and
understands what they're getting into
there's a trade-off like we talked about
earlier
there's a status about being a fighter
about being the best in the world about
combat achilles being on top of the
world there's a trade-off to that too
you can die
yeah so you don't have to do it but if
you want the status
well yeah but listen to this too look at
my life i live in brownsville brooklyn
i'm going to cut off welfare i'm going
to die in this building if i don't rob
and steal
i'll get shot from stealing somebody's
[ __ ] i'll get caught and get put to jail
for the rest of my life
i'mma die and get paid money my life is
worth it i thought
i forfeited my life for it if i died
[ __ ] it i signed the contract
don't you think you know how many people
all over the world you don't think you
think you know how many other people
would have no [ __ ] say that and they got
talent some people don't know how to
fight the [ __ ] i do it for money
yeah yeah you have to get the word
please
nobody care about dying that's what it
comes to the concept of when the real
concept
no one cares about dying we're not going
to eat there's no thought
we don't think about that about that
yeah
um yeah that argument is it goes nowhere
you know because like you said i mean
that's that's part of why people do it
you know it's because the stakes are so
high and you look at the why people
watch it
because the stakes are so high right
it's it's exciting and
this is why i think that bare knuckle is
really starting to take off is because
it is fast people when they sit down
want to be interested especially in
today's generation with all the social
media everything is happening out there
they don't want to wait for something to
happen they don't want to wait for a
story line to play out they want it now
yeah bare knuckle is that kind of
fighting where it's happening
now yeah where is that at it's at four
bears casino in newtown
north dakota awesome and um i'll tell
you what i did before what's that like
oh yeah
yeah north dakota man well i tell you
the native american territory it is and
it's it's a beautiful place i would love
to go see it
you know i mean it's a beautiful
wasn't that cool though yeah yeah this
is
my experience there was awesome those
guys are really proud people they put on
i mean they're just the way they are
when you go there they treat you with
respect
their casino is pretty much brand new
even the event center itself is new
the area around it is just i mean it is
loaded with oil you see oil wells
everywhere wow
so there's a lot of money running
through there not long just with the
indian reservation but also
with the oil and stuff that goes on
there man it's tremendous right now
wow there's a lot like when i drove from
the airport to there i must have saw
at least two to three hundred and this
is no i'm not kidding you two to three
hundred different oil things going on
it's everywhere drive from there
interesting
never would have thought that yeah why
don't you think about going to business
with them
your fighting stuff goes well with them
you can get a contract with the
with the casino yeah so right now man
we're excited
to be there and work with them and we
look forward to a long relationship with
them for sure
yep three bears north dakota
are you still fighting ken no i don't
you know that's funny
that's funny when people say that
because like i uh there's other people
that have mentioned it on their shows
and
people are still fighting well you're in
great shape man i'm just curious
you're in [ __ ] great shape i wrestle
like i've got a show coming out of an
impact on the 20th of september where
i'm
not 20 september 20th of october i don't
even remember i got so much stuff going
on but
i'm wrestling for impact i got a couple
shows i'm doing with them
i'm excited to to be in the ring and
wrestle but mark coleman came out and
started saying stuff about fighting me
bearing up well me and mark are friends
we're good friends and me and him we're
joking about it he says hey dude we just
run with this so we ran with it right he
said yeah
but not once did i ever say i was
fighting he did but i never said that
right and so people just picked it up
and started thinking we're gonna fight
then they started saying well he's too
old to fight i don't know what he's
thinking maybe he needs the money and
they're all speculating on this you're
threat you're
watching my name going hey ask me
yeah ask me i never said i was why are
you saying
why are you saying that they're scared
of you man oh my goodness all the
[ __ ] talking heads are scared
help me little [ __ ] help me yeah
so tell me what was that guy that killed
himself kevin the black guy kevin
something
randleman random women yeah think about
they had mental illness did something
happen what happened
i used to watch him fight a minute yeah
he was a beast he was
an [ __ ] a great wrestler
amazing speed yeah he's fast yeah wow
he's a great wrestler man good dude too
he was not a punk he was a nice guy
and i really hated to see that happen
but you know i mean in this business man
it really when especially when you get
along in the tooth and you start moving
out of that and you're trying to find
yourself
in another career when everybody wants
you and you're important and then you
get the end of your career
and you just got a small amount of
people that kind of want to step on you
as you're going out the door and i think
that's kind of what happened was it just
he just didn't
there was no one there to keep him
lifted up and he got depressed because
it's a hard thing to do
i mean i mean i'm sure mike can speak to
this too because it was tough for me
i'm gonna probably didn't kill myself
i'm glad you did yeah
but it's hard for a fighter who is the
best in the world
literally the best in the world and then
to say
okay you're not relevant anymore that is
that's a hard truth
no no forget not being relevant and
they're saying they treat you like
that really booyah right there and then
you gave free tickets with brought them
in your parties your after-party
little coming your answer right let them
sleep over your house they don't give a
[ __ ]
yeah they would never [ __ ] their nasty
ass when you let somebody
just because they're around you they're
trying to [ __ ] them nasty no good
[ __ ]
then they say [ __ ] you mike that's the
truth man
i tell you there's a lot of klingons
guys that just like are in your camp
that constantly are there when the
party's happening and everything's going
well
the minute it turns they spit on you and
that is that's so hard to deal with
because it's very hard
i know with me and i know what mike
talked so bad about you yeah
they took care of their family their
mother they didn't know what out of the
country was you took care of it you put
them on planes probably
you did a nice thing and he says you're
a piece of [ __ ]
they might testify against you in court
yeah
man i can't be saying that it pierces my
heart because those are people you care
about and then all of a sudden they turn
on you it breaks your heart
it does it hurts you madness is the
woman that you loved and told everything
about you how you love them she's the
love of your life and then you see you
understand saying you're a piece of [ __ ]
you abuse her you're
nothing this and that oh god
i'm such a sucker
it's so interesting you know that people
do that
it hurts just hearing him say that
because it brings back memories you know
we all do money attracts those kind of
people
um you know and you just don't see the
colors until it's gone so you don't
until you're out so you're
you're struggling yourself colors you
don't want to see it it's too good to be
true you don't want to make this i want
to see this light is what it is
too good to expose it for what it is i
don't even want to believe you're lying
to me i don't believe i don't want to
believe you [ __ ] this guy behind my
back
i don't even want to believe i know
you're telling me but i don't believe it
don't want to deal with it don't want to
do it yeah
you didn't do it no you didn't [ __ ]
just move on man it hurts too much i
don't want to see that i don't want to
deal with it
he's in there listening and i ain't
infecting i thought i was
tough i thought it was a badass time my
heart got broken that's a
[ __ ] i ain't [ __ ] that's a true
man that's just just hearing i mean i
like i said i just
i mean it's ditto right i mean you just
feel it yeah yeah kind of just
go through those thoughts again where
you were at and the people that you
thought were your friends and you
thought you didn't
these [ __ ] i love them too you
still love them but they just rot into
this
toxic too you can't help them that kill
you
that's i think that's the hardest part
like he just said that you still love
them you still care about them
and there's a lot of them and you and
you you just kind of rationalize it in
your head like well maybe i was part of
the problem
and maybe you maybe i was like because i
wasn't the nicest person either when i
was at the top at the same time man
it's just you just can't believe that
people that were that close to you on
the inner circle
would literally just kick you in the
nuts and just not care just literally
not care
and then we have to look at from this
perspective and go outside of ourselves
and say
no this is what you need to grow we know
what you need you don't know what you
need [ __ ] this is what you need
to grow
you know when god talks to us we know
it's him but we don't know how to
we don't know how to finance him you
know we don't know how to say hey god
just told me this because that sounds
like [ __ ] god didn't tell me [ __ ]
but he did just send me this
who said it who said i'm not smart
enough to think this [ __ ] up then who
said it
right who said it yeah yeah when you
start thinking it was you
that's when things start going wrong
because you ain't that smart
[Laughter]
i'm not that smart that's working on
this [ __ ] ain't me i ain't thinking of
this [ __ ] no it's too deep for me is
just
transmissions man thinking about this
[ __ ] it's the transmissions we received
yeah wow man yeah working
yeah exactly man ken is there anything
else you want to hit before we wrap it
up want people to know about you where
you're at how to get in contact with you
yeah kenshamrock.com
and um also uh valor bk valerie
okay that's where we have all of our
instagram social media sites
you can go there and check us out you
want to get tickets go check that out
well listen big bear not go to me
don't get promoted enough how do you get
promoted how do you promote it i mean at
a big
level because it's not getting promoted
enough well i think it's first time we
came out for that first week they
promoted the [ __ ] they must have spent
every nickel they had in their pants
to promote it because when was that when
they first when they had those first
pilots
maybe a year ago almost a year six
months ago
yeah yeah yeah eight months ago they
started having all the fights that
everybody knew about it the octagon
square everybody was fighting in there
and then it stopped so now you're just
coming back
yeah i think what we got to do is
basically and this has been our approach
since the beginning is that we got to
educate people on what they're watching
once we can start getting the education
out there that this is not barbaric and
this isn't something that
is coming out from the streets and it's
not sanctioned and it's not professional
we're bringing in professional fighters
and to be able to understand that
people say oh well it's bare knuckle oh
somebody's going to get hurt the reality
of it is it's not because
when you're fighting bare knuckle you
can break your hands so you got to ease
up on your punches
and plus and bare knuckle fighting this
is something i do agree because i know
about better
mostly um they stop the fights because
the guys get cut later
yeah so they ain't nobody's taking a
beating right here three times four time
boom
[ __ ] start opening up you're not
defending yourself you're gonna start
opening up so even though it
looks more more violent because of the
blood
yeah but it's just more cuts yeah
visually
imagine taking three but nobody ain't
nobody in this court goes
gonna let a fight be enough we'll take
three rounds of beating right right
no no yeah yeah one round might be
they might get too ugly on one nobody's
gonna take a beating well
let me get a little deeper than that too
i might think about this and it just
happened about a month ago where you got
a guy that's really tough
right and so this guy knocks him down
three or four times but the guy keeps
getting up
and because he's so tough and that he
has a chin
he keeps getting up but he's he's taking
brain damage but you can't see it you
can't see it yeah
so but with bare knuckle that will never
happen because when a punch lands like
those punches were landing
guys are going to get cut they're going
to get broken noses there's going to be
blood
and they're going to stop the fight as
opposed to
boxing gloves where you're going to hit
a guy 100 times and he may be cut once
but he just took 100 brain shots right
yeah yeah yeah so that's very good the
purpose of
and it can't happen somebody but the
purpose of really where people get hurt
is because um
the continual pounding over time yeah
in the gym and everything all the time
they get aneurysms sometimes people are
born with aneurysms
and they may die the first time you get
hit and they may they get you may die
after 20 years of getting hit and no one
knows when you're gonna die but you're
gonna die
even in sparring like i mean in barranca
you don't spar right you use double in
bags you try to be more accurate you
don't need power
and then when you spar with actual
gloves on you're not trying to hit hard
because all you're trying to do is get
your footwork in and you're handling so
the sparring is much
much less than it would be if you're
trying to train for an mma fight or a
boxing fight because you have to get
those rounds in that are aggressive
with baronacho you don't you don't have
to because you know that when you hit
somebody
with your fists they will count so you
don't have to go
15 rounds or 12 rounds or five five
minute rounds it's three
three minute rounds and it from the bell
to the bell
fight is on
very interesting very exciting american
champion before we could challenge an
english
champion that's where the money's gonna
come and england have been doing it for
500 years something like that what was
ll's ancestor's name
tom tom nelson no tom mullen
john sullivan like yeah he's like um the
16th
tom molina tom mononuka 16 15 16
10. well we have two two guys from
england in our tournament facts we got
one former champion
from england his god beer he's fighting
in this bare knuckle
tournament so james god beard god beard
yeah good name right
whoa intense name right imagine when he
goes to church yeah
[ __ ] bro we in america don't have
nothing on toughness when it comes to
the english
they've been doing they might be better
fighters i'm talking about pure
toughness
like walking through a [ __ ] ball and
you slug out a bunch of big bad mother
no they got that they got to eat with
that yeah it's that gypsy right i mean
they little gypsy circus any of them
yeah there's a whole bunch of
[ __ ] english [ __ ] that are
bunch of fighters [ __ ] fighters yeah
and don't give a [ __ ] if they get killed
to knock down coal in the street just
going for it
they're used to it man yeah they've been
doing that for a year they've been in so
many wars over the years of their
existence
can you imagine well it's interesting to
think about
that and tie it to the united kingdom
the land mass
and how they're such a small piece of
land yet they have so much significance
throughout the history
that oh there's a connection to the
connections to the romans and the great
yeah yeah it's very rich in history too
man
yes man well ken it's been an absolute
honor man to have
you here thank you man i appreciate it
thank you so much pleasure my friend
amazing to share your story and your
insight it's really powerful stuff
girlfriend get together and show love
you know maybe you can go to the
um gravesite together yeah that would be
beautiful that's something i hope for
you know like i said i'm not a person
who wants to
hold i want to make sure that i don't
have anything when i move on in life
that i have to have grudges or hold
grudges because i'm not about that
listen ken right believe it or not right
we're not we're almost it's almost over
for us yeah
we're here that's right ego probably
tells me that bad as we healthy we look
good
but it's almost over we're here for a
short time now yeah
it's almost over can't be mad can't go
to can't leave here being mad at
somebody we love
that's it brother no no question i mean
i had beefs with tito ortiz i had beefs
with dana i went to every single one of
those guys
and said hey man i'm sorry and put our
piece behind us because i felt like
i was involved in this great thing that
people love so much and that the fans
deserve to be able to go to events and
not have to worry about
guys that have feuds with one another so
that was important to me to make sure
that we
we bury that and that we can move on and
just just be friends with each other so
the fans can enjoy the history
and that's awesome i noticed about most
fighters the majority of us just say
98 95 of us you know where we come from
we fight for pride
and we're not businessmen and so people
take advantage of us because of
our pride because we want to be somebody
because we're never nobody we're always
nobody now we want to be somebody we
don't think about no [ __ ] money
we fight for free yeah yeah yeah i would
fight for free
if they let me fight you know what i
mean yeah just they won't let me fight
yeah just get me out there let me fight
the best guy
man and i even said it many times until
until we started making money and i
realized
i was i was a mark he's like hey can't
come over here we'll take you
so i realized it was a business then but
yeah that's kind of how i felt man was
like man just put me in a ring i want to
fight
they'd be talking about some guy oh he's
i'll fight him i said i'll fight him
you know you're not ready not yet mike
we'll give you a chance you're not ready
for them yet
well but i still would have fought him
here to kick my ass but i don't know
i wouldn't have been afraid of it maybe
i would've heard
my intentions would have been the
[ __ ] hurdle back down to no one
yeah words to live by guys
well amazing episode thank you again ken
it's really an honor to have you here
mike great episode incredible everybody
thank you so much for listening to this
episode of hot boxing
be sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel hop up hot boxing with mike
tyson
check out our website
hotboxingpodcast.com
a lot of great stuff there all the
episodes merch
etc good stuff i'm evan britton
i'm mike tyson and i'm ken shamrock
peace
peace out everybody here
oh that was great now thank you thank
you man thank you
[Music]
two